se lanzó con la promesa de luchar contra
la pobreza y la corrupción
el clérigo ultraconservador ebrahim
raisi contó desde el principio con el
respaldo del líder supremo de irán el
ayatolá ha calificado raíz y como una
persona confiable y con mucha
experiencia en 2016 camaney lo nombró
director de i manresa una fundación
benéfica que supervisa varios negocios y
donaciones del país camaney también lo
hizo jefe del poder judicial en 2019 dos
años después de perder la contienda
presidencial ante hassan rohan y en las
elecciones anteriores asesinas astray si
es visto como alguien cercano al líder
supremo de irán alí khamenei es
conservador ideológicamente partidario
de la revolución y también religioso así
que él cumple con muchas de las
expectativas text of words boxes
pero la candidatura también ha recordado
su presunto rol en las ejecuciones
masivas de prisioneros políticos durante
la década de 1980 raíz y nunca se
refirió al tema públicamente y tampoco
el gobierno reconoció que dichos
asesinatos hubiesen ocurrido en el mismo
reid y también enfrenta críticas
internacionales por su papel en una
serie de ejecuciones masivas en 1988 en
irán en mesas de discusiones murieron al
menos 5.000 personas al final de la
guerra entre irán e irak
rise y está sancionado por el gobierno
de eeuu para drew scarlan como
partidario de una línea dura raíz y
pertenece al campo ultra conservador que
desconfía de occidente especialmente de
eeuu